Our culture is the main thing that makes Port Swigger different.
Lots of companies have smart people, great ideas, they work hard, but they can still be
pretty miserable places to be and they can still fail to achieve their full potential.
So what is our culture like? There are several facets to it. We are certainly ambitious,
we only hire the very best people, we never compromise on that, we set ourselves stretch
goals, everything we decide to do, we aim to do it to an exceptional level. We do deliver
amazing things, our products and services, we constantly raise the bar, we focus on the
long term and in general we do things different. We don't follow the herd.
Within our team we are mutually supportive, we look after each other. Our people can ask
for help and know it will be given. There are no stupid questions, no one gets beaten up
for making a mistake. We learn the lessons and we move on. Our team leaders are there to enable
their people to succeed. And the leader is only successful when their team is successful.
Our work is highly collaborative. We work together on everything. We share ideas and work in progress.
We're transparent with information. We minimise hierarchy. Anyone can challenge anyone else
or suggest ideas. And we make decisions together. No one dictates what we do based on their perceived
rank or status. We are agile in everything that we do, not just software delivery. We take small steps,
deliver a small piece of value and get feedback. We're quite happy to change our minds when it turns
out something isn't working. We work on the basis that if it stops being fun, then we're doing it wrong.
Our work is something that we thrive on, we get excited about. Not everyone in the world is that fortunate.
We are generous to everyone. We pay our people what they're worth, not just what we think we can get
away with. We give everyone a stake in the business through ShareOptions. We give back to our community.
That's both our industry through all of our knowledge output that we give away for free.
And also the wider world through charitable giving. Now, some people looking in from the outside say,
yeah, it's kind of cute that you have this strong culture that you care about. But ultimately,
if you want to be successful, you're going to have to compromise on that. You'll only go so far before
this commitment to your culture is holding you back. Well, I fundamentally disagree. And I think
that perspective completely misses the point. Our culture isn't a perk that's nice to have,
and which we have to balance against our ambition to succeed. Really, our culture is a superpower.
It's what enables us to be successful. Take away our culture. And not only would Portswiga be
a much less fun place to be, but we'd also achieve a lot less than we do. Fundamentally,
our culture reflects the core motivations for why Portswiga exists in the first place.
We want to enjoy our work, have fun, deliver incredible things, be successful, and be a force
for good in the world. I don't see how we could achieve all those objectives at the same time,
if we didn't have a culture like ours.